regard de la victoire pour un colis
suspect ayant l'apparence la ville pour
des de la sensuelle en là les camions
les plans daniel wendel l'actuel et
voilà milieu gauche l'amendement est
bien plus la mine à gauche tu vois la
capilla médias voilà quatre ans voilà
voilà
les camions vont se croiser de ban ki
moon est arrivé devant de tous les côtés
ils savent a tous croisé quadras qui
barrait la loi du les boîtes on voit
plus beaucoup tout à leur plein
l'hommage au rang des autres peuvent
aider son run je l'assumé qui s'échappe
à droite le seul en est un peu trop on
entre dans la ville de hem la mine qui
est de l'emploi
la ville est devant toi à gauche avec
les camions dedans il fonde la poussière
non mais je pense pas trop quand même un
bon c est joli
laurent dousselin rentrer dans l'orient
voila voila tu vois là voilà quand tu
vois les vignes il avait été très bonne
en grand paris commence un petit peu
plus loin le problème voir on va le voir
quoi
je pense qu'il faut montrer plus vers la
gauche voilà voilà pas plus de la
facture sera moins cher voilà c'est
super beau ce regard là bill yotive ali
kalahi raber la bible avec la gauche un
voile à disparaître derrière c'est donc
aller oui on peut s'approcher
on vient les camions un peu c'est votre
écoute 1
j'ai même pas de photo
tous les camions dans le soleil le sol
et ce besoin d'affectif équipe qui l'a
vu le chemin est pas un propos avec la
ville et à cause d'un genou lui pas de
la mine et bien la gauche et qu'elle
aboutir de gants des gens qui
travaillent un petit peu de l'écran avec
la tournée vers l'art
l'avion du retour
pétanque
tholot
elle appelle à mes mains sont à peu près
de suva l'ariana partout d'ailleurs 21 à
la droite
pourquoi tu vas tu vas les côtés ou vers
la zone mais bien à côté et bon enfant
albinos il ya 27 ans la brillance et le
tim raines la vie des bêtes qui
travaille j'ai envie d'aller sur le
sous-poids tout de suite je vais y aller
ou par un oeil allez c'est bon pour toi
ce mois là mais pas le second regard on
va se faire encore un coup là sur le mec
qui travaille et camions à peu vers la
gauche voilà voilà voilà plus un peu
pertes à droite on va les envoyer le peu
qui reste voilà l'un des meneurs de
camions là qui travaillent sur hull
on avait à voir avec ça mais là on va
passer du bon côté du soleil de travail
ou va cesser ou la voilà ce qu'on voit
là par la propre histoire ses larmes
on voit bien la ville quand même et
rendre le lendemain tu vois la bordure
quant à l'impression que avant
traitement de la peau tu vas pas de
bordure
caudron ses parents ouais
mais ben toi tu te plains tu réponds ça
paie pour voir par dessus le besco mais
la cote le sofa écosse on arrête avec la
rva sur une autre ok ok et là on va
passer au dessus d'un papa c'est encore
pire